nationwide the pace of hospital
admissions is at an all-time high for
people under the age of 50. we did hit
one million vaccine doses administered
yesterday that's good news because
that's the first time that has happened
in nearly two months our lead national
correspondent david bagno joins us from
scott louisiana many areas of that state
are running out of icu beds david good
morning unfortunately that's part of the
story too
it is gail good morning my friend listen
for the first time in 16 days yesterday
they did not set a record here in
louisiana for covet 19 hospitalizations
but they've still got 3 000 people
hospitalized statewide with coving this
morning we want to tell you more about a
fairly new treatment the doctors say has
proven to be overwhelmingly effective at
helping to keep covert patients out of
the hospital
inside of those iv drips is a powerful
weapon in the fight against covet 19
monoclonal antibodies lab-grown proteins
that help the body target and eliminate
covet infection according to dr thomas
gallet chief medical officer at saint
francis medical center in monroe
louisiana they have become the most
effective therapy yet it's done a great
job of helping high risk patients stay
out of the hospital the therapy is
becoming more available at hospitals and
clinics around the country but it is
only administered after infection within
10 days of the first symptoms and before
those symptoms get too severe what type
of sickness do you usually say that's
too sick to receive if they are having
profound
oxygen requirements continued high grade
fevers dehydration since july the first
we've given about 1700 doses one of
those doses went to 42 year old scotty
johnson we were there when he got his
infusion three weeks ago in monroe as
covid was attacking his body it feels
like somebody's choking you
you start coughing but nothing comes out
this week we followed up with him and we
met his wife meg they both got the
antibody treatments right around the
same time i just really started feeling
good about it three four days ago
probably
but uh i feel like i'm like 90 percent
now while scotty did not get the vaccine
meg did my wife got the antibody
treatment
on thursday i tested possum on friday on
saturday she was back up cleaning the
house and doing dishes and
like it never even bothered while the
antibody treatments can be effective
they are not a substitute for vaccines
says cbs news medical contributor dr
david agus there's no question a vaccine
is better than an antibody but in the
case where you're immune suppressed and
you can't make a good response to a
vaccine they're life savers so this is
an important part of our arsenal but it
certainly is not the only weapon in our
arsenal vaccines are the front line no
question about it to fight a virus in
today's world and that is something
johnson acknowledges he learned
firsthand do you plan to get vaccinated
heck yes
tech yes
my wife was vaccinated i wasn't she
stayed sick for two days i stayed sick
for ten
and uh it was miserable
absolutely miserable
there you go a first-hand account now
listen even with that antibody treatment
scott said he felt terrible for five
days he said he couldn't sleep for 60
hours so even with the treatment it was
everything he went through that led him
to say hey listen when i can get that
vaccine i'm going to get it and you know
lastly i asked him where did you get
your information that led you to believe
that maybe you shouldn't get vaccinated
he said social media and i said who were
you listening to and he said not the
doctors
but going forward
he says that's all he's listening to the
doctors
[Music]
heck no to social media heck yes to the
vaccine david thank you very much for
bringing that story home for us